[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
alors
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qui t'arrive
ce qui parle et je suis je vais aller au
ski ah bon et je descendais une piste
noire et mais mes jambes n'ont pas pris
la même décision a donc dû coucher très
très mal et je vais voter marine le pen
je veux que les pistes noires retournent
dans leur pays voilà ce que je veux
non seulement ça commençait mal peur
celle qui a drucker je connais de ce nom
mais je serais incapable chef de choeur
voilà déjà
michel drucker ne se
méfie bride a peur après les couches pas
les couches
et voilà le de ambulatoire de michel
attends pas non non la figure d'un
signalement va s'inverser beaucoup posé
là derrière l'as si bien le le
déambulateur est ce que je peux l'avoir
devant pascal s'il veut faire un petit
tour du plateau michel mademoiselle
mademoiselle s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
ça vient
si vous restez derrière michel on sait
jamais ça peut arriver michel drucker et
quand même quelqu'un m'attende à csg
tarifs j'arrive n'arrive à shariff they
were messieurs vainqueur
[Applaudissements]
chaque crise est 6ème
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
michel
ça c'est après l'émission là bas tout le
monde dit qu'il est dur car il arrive
aux genoux
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
centoni de lil wayne et une scène
absolument extraordinaire où joey starr
danse dans la boîte
[Musique]
à
ah c'est toi mon cher un sétois
bien oui bien sûr le chien dans we lost
tapes un chien aveugle c'est l'eau en
vin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'accord comme toute cette semaine e
j'ai plein de tweets n'hésitez pas à
réagir à l'émission hashtag slt la
semaine dernière on se met entre autres
cyril féraud réanimateurs de slam tout
le monde doit si elle fera tiquer
sagnier la même coupe que sophie davant
et thierry vous êtes moquer de son
public regardez l'extrait
alors cyril soir salut les terriens il
pas les filmer les coulisses de votre
émission en regard à 1
[Musique]
et alors ça n'a pas plu aux gens je ne
cautionne pas je ne cautionne pas du
coup il ya par exemple la méthode femmes
sur twitter qui a réagi l'a dit thierry
ardisson se moque des vieux qui
regardent slam on oublierait presque
qu'il a 68 ans c'est vrai bon la semaine
dernière c'était une émission un peu
spécial d'ailleurs merci beaucoup on
était près d'un million trois cent mille
téléspectateurs ce extraordinaire
avec une pointe à 1 million cet ami
[Applaudissements]
et il faut le savoir tirer quand il fait
le bilan des invités ils utilisent la
chanson des neg'marrons sait
[Musique]
chacun et la semaine dernière ils sont
venus chanter en live les marrons et à
maurice sur twitter nous dit les
neg'marrons en live dans salut les
terriens quand on a les moyens de se
payer groupe pour lancer le jingle voilà
ce que ça donne ils étaient payés lors
il sera en promo alors il faudra leur
dire ce qu'ils attendent le chèque juste
devant l'important
c'est une bonne idée de demander aux
mecs de la sécu est ce soir avec noces à
pois
et puis juste pour pour terminer un
dernier tweet de katy b 45 qui dit
j'adore cette émission je serai dans le
public de celle de samedi prochain dont
théoriquement elle doit être là lé
mikati et neocate y est les eaux a salu
casting
merci katyn continue à envoyer des
tweets bah oui et puis alors juste pour
terminer un petit dernier je sais pas si
c'est une rumeur ou pas mais j'ai lu sur
twitter que laurent baffie avait terminé
d'écrire sa prochaine pièce ouais ouais
ouais ouais tu peux nous en dire un peu
plus ou non non non non ça va être un
triomphe comme dame la routine non mais
sérieux je préfère demander parce qu'il
a toujours des rumeurs qui traînent
d'ailleurs rumeur ou pas rumeurs petit
pied sur michel drucker a vu démarrer
molière au théâtre
voilà la rumeur
rumeur ou pas rumeurs le voisin de
michel drucker c'est hugh grant c'est
pas possible ça non mais ouais voilà
ouais c'est toujours d'actualité
rumeur ou pas mon heure la maman d'une
chaîne dont le cas aurait adoré qu'il
épouse anne sinclair ouais ça c'est sûr
c'est vrai et dans son livre rumeur ou
pas rumeurs le papa de michel aurait
adoré qui les pousse dsk
rumeur ou pas vraiment pas s'il
s'appelle ainsi en hommage à la porte de
passy où il a perdu sa virginité à 17
ans
[Rires]
meurt c'était place dauphine
rumeurs ont paru à passy possède un
brevet de technicien agricole ouais
virginie calmels c est à ce jour l'une
des plus jeunes femmes décoré de l'ordre
national du mérite rumeur ou pas rumeurs
parues meurt pas rumeurs et oui la
crise
financière de numericable h drame
s'étant la longue cela donc et rumeurs
ou par hubert artus est atteint de la
même maladie très rare que laurent
baffie
quelle maladie la maladie c'est celle ci
je crois
c'est la bible ce clip donc voila tu te
vois tu reviens avec plaisir
alors salut à tous salut c'est la
première fois que tu fais une de mes
émissions we were fois que je te vois
était était l'humoriste qu'on voit
partout en ce moment en fait avec
emmanuel macron vous êtes
je suis un peu derrière tu dis que tu es
le sosie officiel de laurent ournac ham
avant avant avant sa vente maintenant on
le reconnaît plus un talent a fait
savoir que tu étais cuisinier quand même
un oui tout à fait or après la cuisine
il ya eu en d'art oui on ne demande qu'à
en rire l'émission de laurent ruquier
était pas ce que tu avais été repéré à
avignon par l'assistante de l'anglais
oui tout à fait il ya six ans maintenant
et qui m'a proposé de venir faire
l'émission à la rentrée dit ça m'a fait
gagner cinq ans oui je pense que ça nous
a tous fait gagner entre cinq et dix ans
et la nation catherine chez nous regarde
alors après donc ruquier il ya eu artur
hein le décor pencher bail que j'ai
essayé de redresser avec mon poids mais
qui n'a jamais que ça n'a jamais marché
jamais et c'est vrai quand on marche sur
ce truc on a l'impression d'être gérard
depardieu en fin de soirée au
début d'après midi
vrai booster médiatique ça sera ça
[Musique]
oui
alors danse avec les stars a obtenu
quand même le premier disent que chris
marquès a distribué pour mayence
contemporaine avec pietragalla moi peu
importe les notes enfin la danse avec
petra c'est un vrai un kiff je m'en
souviendrai toute ma vie celle là c'est
vrai que tu voulais devenir un petit rat
de l'opéra non non non non non des
planches déjà voulait pas sens de ce
parc et se souvient encore de mandela et
la artus
ces deux drames
massa
tu participes à une émission de france 2
qui s'appelle actually ti présenté par
thomas thouroude qui s'arrête
tu présentes la cérémonie des globes de
cristal on avait dit qu'on en parle est
un fiasco sans président
tu sais que je suis inquiet pour moi ce
soir tu porte malheur ou quoi
les globes de cristal tu tu veux
vraiment qu'on en parle nous avons parlé
oui parce que ça restera dans les
annales de la télévision le président
est pas là les micro marché pas
catherine deneuve un marché sur sa robe
il y avait le monsieur là qui me
balançait des bouts de pain des remixes
ans on a chanté dans l'indifférence
générale
il ya eu un bon moment c'est quand
luchini est monté sur scène mais il a
dit jeudi une soirée de merde formidable
il a été brillantissime comme d'habitude
mais c'est ça qu'il ya que lui qui peut
faire ça parce qu'il a quand même passé
quatre minutes à faire un discours où il
disait à tous les gens dans la salle
vous êtes des merdes ouais écoutez pas
vous est irrespectueux et tout c'est
génial elle génère alors qu'il est un
stand mardi on vous respecte rien
c'était leur équipe et leur c'était le
titanic cette émission
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
regarde à quoi ça ressemblait t sur
valeo ont fait grève des lycées ces
données ont fait relâche jusqu'à ce
qu'ils mettent nos micros un peu plus
fort halo 1 1 o o et là ça va mieux ou
pas toujours pas versés aux traders en
fait ce qu'on te dit depuis le début
c'est qu'il faut que tu augmentes leçon
voilà si c'est possible et si tu entends
pas ce que je te dis c'est que déjà tu
l'a mal fait oui
tu vois et si même moi je ne me sens pas
c'est quand même un souci art ah ah ah
c'est mieux
bon moyen bon et que tout va continuer
comme ça on est déjà en route pour
remettre le prix de la meilleure série
meilleur téléfilm j'ai tout de suite
appelé de comédiens sur scène lucie
lucas que vous retrouvez régulièrement
dans clem sur une autre chaîne bien sûr
et enfin yaniss lespert que vous
retrouver lui aussi dans la série fais
pas ci fais pas ça sur une autre je
l'aide 11
bon jour
pour le golden globe de cristal de la
meilleure série et du meilleur téléfilm
est ce que tu as vu comme on est sympa
c'est qu'ils jouent tous les deux dans
des séries et pour les accueillir on met
un truc de sous le soleil tombe elle
voulait pas un
golden globe de la soirée la plus jeune
homme de l'année
le bilan après ce but est de sortir de
chez toi non non non non parce qu'en mai
l'émission culte de maintenant à vous et
déjà les cultes déjà je vois là je vais
être sur toutes les chaînes période de
noël pour les bêtises et donc ça c'est
plutôt cool mais bon pour moi et non il
ya en fait c'était tellement
catastrophique que tous les gens dans la
salle en fait ils nous regardaient avec
avec une faille on avait un soutien
quand les gens dans la salle il dit
désolé on voit que vous couler mais on
peut rien ils ont ramé les pauvres ça va
être dur de faire mieux les brochets
dans tous les cas franchement c'est bon
alors ce qui est bien tu sais que tu
remonte sur scène le 1er avril oui avec
une pièce qui s'appelle duel à david et
john hathaway sa mairie a assez au
théâtre des feux de la rampe alors le
pitch c'est les habitants de david et
jonah tarn qui choisissent un nouveau
shérif et les candidats s'opposent dans
des duels à mort et le héros c'est qui
ce temps éleveurs de cochons tout à fait
c'est un éleveur de cochons toujours
rôle c'est sébastien chartier qui est un
comédien tout-petits excellence en main
non pas du tout mais quelle physique de
désolé si on me regarde l'émission mais
de la victime et donc c'est ce qu'il
nous fallait il a été inscrit par la
[__] qui est amoureuse de lui deux
plutôt petit et qu'est ce tu fais toi
non moi je fais je fais believe the big
le méchant ah ouais mais ils habitent en
français et
et je fais le méchant je fais et est ce
que tu as mountain avec cartman
il peut y avoir par une petite scène
entre indiens et cow-boys un peu coquin
voilà
et puis attend seul état qui s'appelle
signant un point tu es diffusée sur ces
vite le 11 mars donc je vous demande
d'être là vraiment pour regarder c'est
ce que sony fera plaisir après la soirée
des globes de cristal
il faut l'aider ce gars là il faut
regarder il ya un sketch dans son
spectacle que j'adore c'est le québécois
à ces gens tu connais michel de
québécois le québécois on va regarder le
québécois
[Musique]
j'étais complètement bourré je me
souviens de rien j'ai juste des flashs à
faire ça va les gars ans
j'aurais pas dû le dire ça marin quand
c'est gênant je vais tourner du coup
mais je m'attends donc pas c'est bonnard
c'est pour ça que je voulais dire en
fait je voulais vous raconter surtout
qu'il ya un an et alors jetez pas bien
du tout
j'étais pas bien pas bien pour bientôt
bien comme les poils les poils pubiens
c'est de l'humour au québec c'est rigolo
et
un en suisse et de la comprennent box et
les intimes et gtl n'ont pas dit ce
qu'on dit en europe et j'étais jeune
j'étais au bord du gouffre est vraiment
il ya un an j'étais proviennent dessous
c'est là au bord du coup je voulais
je me suis dit micky
non je me suis dit mike qui arrêtent
micky faut que tu avances
ce que j'ai fait la gourdasse g arrivé
en bas je me suis cassé des deux bras un
diamant la jambe gauche complètement
pété et deux fois le coccyx
pas ça ce n'est pas à cause de la chute
c'était johnny
johnny un petit infirmiers très
sympathique
comme quoi un avant bras ça rentre
oui
et en attendant l'heure de ce n était
rien je vous propose un grand kiff très
grand kiff passi et stomy vous avez
chanté avec les enfants
attention attention
ce jour sont unies derrière exactions
et
à
moi à boire
mon papa à moi et d'un gangster il fait
partie du ministère avait sorti tout
droit d'une ambiance folle mais le matin
ils m'amènent à l'école est fatigué de
ces soirées agitées
il me dit que ces studios mais
c'est vrai qu'ils travaillent dur dur
mais par contre il a du rouge à lèvres
sur les avis ça c'est sûr tu es
l'ascenseur il fait des clins d'oeil aux
mamans accompagnant leurs enfants mon
papa c'est plus fort quand ils entendent
pas pour guy s'évapore pas besoin de
revolver
à moi à boire et à gand c'est pourquoi
pas moi est un concert il nous fait voir
si simon schuster amer salut les
terriens la vacance to play si vous
l'âge d'or du rap français
toutes les grandes capes les sûretés les
images de son sommet spectre les
programmes je perds et directement gect
je suis un enfant de la télé fons des
heureux diffusé plage pâques dans le
passé conditionné par b osaka des séries
ping pong à l'américaine cet artiste à
tresques et tous qui ancrait tout une
question pour un champion par le mois
d'émission info marco je connais les
ragots je suis par jour comme columbo
hama lundi un simple match où le jour du
seigneur tu as tes les freenautes
naturel télécommande ans chez les as
peur à cause de leur bêtise mon crâne
est un bouillon de culture pub dans les
vignes jeu du feu l'amour et laventure
la une la deux pour puis dans leurs jeux
à 3
j'ai zappé je mate un 5 à 6 ans sont les
compliments coup l'argent de kiel et le
sexe à la télé n'a vu là que leurs jeux
à 3 l'accord que ça et je braque
français à 6 ans sont les complices
appelé vol des gels et san roque du
canapé l'âge d'or du rap français à lui
écrire dans toute la france salue
qu est ce qui me motive
dans ma famille raconte ainsi voilà
c'est qu'il me
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
par
semaine
ce sens
salut les telle série net 1
dans votre tour du samedi soir nous on
vient de retrouver sur ses mii pour
ardisson est bâti désormais il faut
taper
bien tu vois là le meilleur des publics
et parapublics de michel ils sont
traînés
aux fanatiques aux gamins alors premier
terriens invité ce soir le dernier des
grands animateurs
hétérosexuels non drogué l'import
télévision michel ritter
[Musique]
me la jcat veulent
de même bon soir ancien dirigeant de
canal + et d'endémol vous êtes la
première adjointe d'alain juppé la
mairie de bordeaux et là c'est le drame
encore attendre vous êtes fondatrice de
la droite libre et vous soutenez
françois fillon rassurez moi c'est pas
un soutien fictif
autres derrière invité ce soir les stone
et charden du rap français
on a ici
[Musique]
j'hésitais stratégique et avec peter et
sloane mais je trouve les bons autres
terriens invité ce soir le danseur le
plus drôle de france à moins que ce soit
l'humoriste qui danse le mieux artus
l'émission s'appelle salut les terriens
le bon et gréements me sentir il est en
ce sens
m
maintenant voici mon cdd tom villa
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voiture est super on a un plateau de
folie ce soir à tout ça je dois dire ce
soir site nos premiers invités sais pas
si et stomy bugzy comprennent le dire
c'est la classe si c'est le frère de
cyril hanouna avec
ace commise c'est le fils de patrick
balkany
[Musique]
à
alors vous êtes là pour nous annoncer
l'arrêt formation du groupe le ministère
amer avec michel drucker
dans les airs par contre attention les
gars parce que michel la seule plante
qui consomment c'est pas de la marocaine
c'est de la verveine
c'est pas la même soirée voilà non
mais très bonne idée très bonne idée
c'est cette association parce que c'est
avec michel c'est le meilleur moyen pour
gérer se faire arrêter par les policiers
sévenans baissé je raconte juste une
petite anecdote parce que michel c'est
la seule personne que j'ai vu je vous
jure que c'est vrai passer la douane il
oublie son passeport l'aéroport et il
arrive quand même à prendre l'avion
nationale ceni oui non mais c'est quand
même fort bah oui il a fallu quand même
un tout petit peu négociées l'a dit
faites gaffe sinon j'appelle e brigitte
bardot et laisser passer mais c'est une
longueur
donc voilà précise denis bodi vous nous
parler de la tournée l'âge d'or du rap
français c'est un peu comme la tournée
âge tendre et tête de bois mais en rap
et disons que maintenant votre public
porte toujours des casquettes mais là
c'est pour cacher une calvitie et non
mais parce qu'aujourd'hui vous avez tous
entre 40 et 50 ans rassurez-vous il nie
toujours des mères mais avec du viagra
et pis c'est courageux parce
qu'aujourd'hui elles ont soixante dix
ans et presse de l'aide aux personnes
âgées donc c'est bosser
c'est un concert formidable ça va être à
bercy le 27 mars sur à assassin busta
flex ménélik ministère amer neg'marrons
ne t'y poètes de la rue et plein
d'autres c'est une tournée en
partenariat avec la radio générations et
pôle emploi spectacle de saint denis et
non après toutes ces années on n'aurait
pas eu trop de difficultés à vous
reconnaître et tout parce que je sais
que sur la tournée star 80 ils ont
galéré ils avaient des badges sinon ils
se connaissaient pas du tout il s'est
fait avaler mais qui sont ils sont
gonflés soit c'est le botox soit c'est
les fruits de mer mais il faut arrêter
voilà notre invité suivante
contrairement aux mauvaises langues ce
n'est pas bien ce que vous m'avez dit
thierry ce n'est pas l'aide soignante de
d'alain juppé mais sa première adjointe
à la mairie de bordeaux c'est virginie
calmels
bienvenue vous êtes chevalier de l'ordre
national du mérite et du mérite vous en
avez vous avez bossé chez endemol vous
avez bossé chez canal+ maintenant chez
les républicains à vous entrerez au
panthéon c'est sûr rien que pour ça on
peut l'applaudir vraiment ça fait
alors comme bien le dire tirez vous est
la fondatrice du mouvement droite libre
droite libre c'est comme les vélib sauf
que quand tu montes dessus c'est là que
tu t'aperçois que tu es une route crever
ou kit manque la selle
laxisme ou signer ses
droits alors le choix de votre mari fait
partie de l'équipe de françois fillon
est l'une de vos filles se prennent et
de pénélope bravo c'est bien voilà c'est
par enfant fictif non c'est pas du tout
n'est ce pas
france est
effectif c'est notre invité suivant
c'est l'inventeur de la promotion canapé
c'est monsieur michel drucker
michel il est tellement associé à son
canapé rouge et bientôt il aura un clic
clac à son nom chez ikea le mimi druck
il grince un peu mais très très
confortable puis elle même au niveau des
slogans nabila elle avait déposé son
fameux nommé halo quoi jean marc
généreux et sa j'achète patrick balkany
planque l'argenterie mine où il ya les
flics arrivent et michel lis et bah si
tu nous entends on t'embrasse tellement
de fleurs envoyées vous auriez dû
racheter interflora michel soit plus
rapide set mais ce geste lâche t il été
repris par un jour par thierry way un
hommage à serge gainsbourg tu te
souviens c'était serge et une eau rien
c'est moi j'avais appelé l'émission en
hommage à serge gainsbourg et sert si tu
nous regardes un hommage que je te
rendre ce livre ans ça m'a pas échappé
[Applaudissements]
mais justement aussi en parlant de serge
gainsbourg michel je vous adore mais
vous êtes nuls en anglais parce que il
avait traduit la phrase de gainsbourg à
whitney houston i want to fuck you paris
dit que vous êtes très joli
nelson monfort à côté c'est un
traducteur de l'onu franchement puis
voilà bientôt vivre 20 ans de vivement
dimanche je ne travaille que le que le
week end soit pas par fainéantise et
jusque s'est payée double sait par
contre c'est comme thierry vais
d'ailleurs michel vous êtes un repère
moi mon grand père grâce à michel il
sait quel jour on est voilà il dit pas
on est dimanche mais on est drucker
paris pour le samedi 10 par an dès
samedi mais a redit son voile à yakin
semaine où c'est le bordel parce que à
cause de nagui il sait jamais si on est
le midi ou le soir il sait juste que
c'est l'heure de bouffer
et puis pour terminer cert us mesdames
et messieurs
tout ce qui est très bon
artus un prénom d'origine celte je crois
ça signifie ours ouais c'est ça oui et
arthur ces bretons ça signifie frontière
belge et
non artus était voilà l'une des stars de
dons ne demande qu'à en rire de vendredi
tout est permis de danse avec les stars
dernièrement il n'y a pas que des succès
voilà vous l'avez un petit peu rappelé
il ya les globes de cristal actuel de
l'émission pour tous du routier aussi a
eu 5 à 7 avec arthur voilà c'est vrai
que ça noir sans déconner
tu iras l'équipe de sarkozy pour la
primaire où on savait pas
c'est la salle quand j'aurais été
content d'avoir passé
dernièrement il ya eu effectivement de
danse avec les stars voilà hiatus été
formidables ils étaient jusqu'en finale
il a fini troisième et moi je pense que
la petite boulette c'est il a dansé sur
une rumba sûr je te le dis quand même de
patrick bruel
un break qui comme danser une salsa sur
jacques brel ou face à l'absence comme
choisit pas forcément les chansons
belles chansons inavouables c'était
genre casse saiem ici poussé pas manqué
des choses
mais ça c'était pas dans le spectacle
aussi non non non je démens par tu veux
mon zizi de francky vincent bessat là je
la suive à monsieur
ça mais c'est vrai donc à un ami
[Applaudissements]
en tout cas n'oublions pas de rappeler à
tous les humoristes et il a cartonné le
week end dernier à la cigale voilà on
peut voir la fiche voilà je très belles
affiches sein un hommage à dexter et non
à jean luc reichman tu nous laisses
bonne émission
on sait
on entre ici la souche et tu cela
lepoint fr
et maintenant mesdames messieurs nous
passons à notre grand invité d'honneur
de la semaine
[Musique]
en général en ce moment là les invités
font c'est moi c'est moi drucker rival
en quarts tout il sait que c'est lui
c'est que c'est lui le grand l'invité
d'honneur
michel drucker mesdames messieurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et oui michel drucker 50 ans de
télévision
5000 heures d'archivés télévisuelles
aline à 12000 magnifique et 23000 main
au cul des maquilleuses michel drucker
alors messieurs on va regarder le résumé
de notre carrière
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
et celle d'avant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
c'est ce sont les premières secondes de
mon one man ben oui c'est pour ça bien
sûr j'ai vu le one man on va en parler
j'ai trouvé ça génial j'avais les larmes
aux yeux à la fin ça m'a beaucoup touché
parce que c'est vrai at one man alors
michel on vous demande plus votre âge on
a essayé de vous dater au carbone 14
pour avoir une estimation un peu plus
précise ça fait quand même pas que vous
avez quoi s'étendre plus que moi non 50
puisque moi soixante huit mois
7,7 quel 115 dans quelques mois oui
bravo michel
[Applaudissements]
michel vous êtes en pleine santé
malheureusement ce qui doit tu va
déprimer l'hypocondriaque vous êtes
quand même mais un oui mais je suis
persuadé que j'ai raison en fait c'est
la prévention permet bien sûr mais c'est
tout mais là la fin te donnera raison
mais je suis fils et frère de médecins
j'ai grandi dans cet univers donc la
santé c'est quelque chose qui me
préoccupe matin midi et soir à moi je
suis pareil que vous gg je fais beaucoup
de check up parce que je veux voir
arriver la mort en face parce qu'un
cancer avant d'être un cancer c'est un
petit cancer et comme c'est un petit
cancer on peut s'en débarrasser une fois
que c'est un gros concert c'est mort et
là tu considères peut-être ge dans le
divertissement là
or en décembre 2014 donc michel s'est
fait hospitaliser entre eux même jour
donnant alors qu'il avait rien vous dit
j'adore les hôpitaux les blouses
blanches les coquillettes maintenant
mais michel c'est vrai que l'hôpital
quand on n'est pas malade c'est génial
une coloscopie pour toi c'est comme une
caméra cachée
j'adore les hôpitaux wen dans les
hôpitaux et dans la compote dans les
yaourts le jambon les infirmières formes
généreuses alors vous présentez initial
vivement la télé le dimanche à 16h20 et
à 18h50 vivement dimanche prochain
alors ils m'ont dit non c'est non
s'asseoir sur un canapé pour être
regardé par des gens assis dans un
canapé c'est la plus grande mise en
abyme de la télévision en finale c'est
une trouvaille de stéphanie ait jamais
brader ses failles et la scénographe et
qui fait tous les décors quand il faut
le rappeler quand même je le dis sur
scène j'ai je suis allée à reculons dans
cette tranche là car le succès des
génies page remplacer pas parce qu'il
était irremplaçable succéder à jacques
martin s'est passé si vite il y avait
deux en mairie école des fans mais me
suis dit mais je vais jamais je vais
assurer j'ai beaucoup souffert pendant
un an tout le monde l'a oublié et j'ai
demandé à ma fille quel décor une table
avec des chroniqueurs autour il a
beaucoup et m'a dit mais pourquoi pas un
canapé à 14h on prend le café tous les
français en un canapé plus ou moins
grand je savais pas que ce canapé aurait
une telle important à ouidah pérou c'est
ça fait partie de l'émission mais
vraiment c'est devenu un symbole oui oui
tout à fait alors ce canapé rouge est
tellement confortable qui vous arrive
michel de vous endormir pendant une
interview faisait tellement de métier
que vos lèvres continuer à bouger et ça
a c'est quand même fait quand même
drucker est arrivé à mes invités jean
ley et sur les documents sont à dire de
logan un panneau galles crocodile dundee
il s'endormit mais les premières
questions et il s'est endormi
profondément alors quel succès alors
chez ikea on peut acheter le canapé
michel drucker sauf que le problème
c'est qu'il ya adamo qui est coincée
dedans
[Musique]
ouellette efforts en vue
mais combien de formidables michel
drucker on sait plus oui 15000
formidable 20000 formidable élan merci
et 2 millions de technétium
vous avez un truc que vous n'avez a pris
un petit peu c'est la bienveillance à
mais là je ne connaissais pas c'est un
mot que j'ignorais après avoir allumé
tout le paf pendant vingt ans thierry
mettez un jour mais finalement tu as
raison il n'y a pas de honte à être
bienveillant ouais voilà exactement
c'est la vérité
alors
un jour j'ai dit que les invités préféré
se faire sucer les drucker quand mr des
chaires 10 ans et michel a répondu sur
un génial thierry ça fait dix ans qu'ils
attendent venir se faire sucer sur mon
canapé et je m'en foutais en fait en
vérité je m'en foutais jusqu'au jour où
vous avez invité ma fille je me dis
quand même il m'invite pas il invite
baffie bon je rêve non je ne sentais
rien contre moi j'attends ce soit et
c'est vrai que si ça c'est pas taire par
ordre de notoriété pour toi voilà que
débarque alors j'ai gueulé jamais
j'avais pris ma fille pour deux raisons
d'abord parce que j'ai une plus que de
la tendresse pour lui et aussi parce que
j'ai des rapports particuliers avec sa
mère a été obligé de faire sauter le
gosse mais ça c'est ma vie privée parce
qu'elle avait envie de construire et lui
voulaient juste baiser
la petite anecdote
alors un jour on se rencontre dans les
cliniciens aux grosses têtes et jeudi à
michel enfin quand même tu m'a jamais
habité pas invité ben vite invité tout
le monde et moi jamais et il m'a dit je
t'invite mais avec ta femme du dakar si
tu m'invites à cause de ma femme tu me
manques non mais j'ai une petite
faiblesse pour pour leur aide pour ta
femme alors sérieusement je pense que
tout le monde m'a dit chérie tu te dru
crise et c'est vrai que je me suis un
peu de bruch les risées mais c'est là
c'est moi ce mode rue crise et parce
qu'on dit jamais je me jean pierre
foucault il est michel c'est un peu
hardie sonné un petit peu un petit peu
devenue bank et chaque année il se lâche
un peu plus je veux du gothique dans
fais gaffe michel parce qu'on commence
par du stand-up ont fini par se coucher
tard on prend plus ses petites pilules
et on n'insulte celle à ce rythme la
semaine prochaine fait un tatouage la
semaine d'après vous pisser sur le
canapé non faut faire gaffe quand même à
allah vous tourner mal michel et je suis
au bord du piercing vous avez écrit sur
les murs de france 2 jean kull delphine
ernotte
oui oui on t'avait michel
ces clans il avait marqué sur les murs
d'europe 1 je recule lagardère c'est 20
que lagardère fait lagardère dit on
virait m'ont viré parce que ça veut dire
je pensais des
sites qui téléphoné à mon ancien patron
qui devait être patrie de caroline ouais
il appelait le bureau de patrick de
carolis respect et 10 et les lagons
quand il a feeling on est en train de
déjeuner
alors vas-y
toi c'est moi que j'ai une photo de
michel qui tirait une latte sur un joint
de guerre moi je me suis envoyé en l'air
avec ta mère
c'est ma mère elle a fait un baptême de
l'air oui il a fait son bonheur
d'hélicoptères avec moi mais c'est vrai
c'est vrai bien sûr c'est vraiment
toujours jeune fille et moi non malades
auraient je pense que j'ai fait moi
c'est moi qui la pousse elle à la traîne
il ya un truc que j'adore de michel
c'est là on voit quand même là la
dimension de michel c'est ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à toi cholet
six mois
c'est parce qu'à ma masseuse il veut
parler
de chute près ce mois ci avait ce soir
oui parce que j maman un peu mous dit
elle est très boudinés mac os x
c'est une bonne soirée de musique aux
soirées de music hall on va pouvoir voir
des numéros à la
corde fixée vestiaires aime bien
à présenter il est le seul mais je suis
c'est le seul patrick sébastien je sais
plus qui je suis bce voilà là c'est ma
cousine on voit bien là
le film là
les jeunes sont prévues avec tokyo parce
qu'avec dix mois
[Applaudissements]
et
si vite
m
sur une chanson
g data fait rire ah ouais ce qui me
plaît c'est qu'ils osent le faire et
s'en fout il a plus de carrière en ce
moment alors michel en arrive à votre
spectacle seul avec vous vous raconter
les boîtes la drogue et d intox et bien
sûr votre terrible addiction au sexe
j'ai vu le spectacle c'est assez
touchants c'est un spectacle tout en
humilité tout seul face au public le
juste que vous arrivez en hélicoptère
sur scène c'est pas grand chose
texter lampard l'effort en spectacle les
gens ils ont pas la télécommande pour
monter le son non je parle fort pour
m'entendre moi je n'entends pas à la
bonne idée s'il t'arrive jeunes pour les
moins de 65 ans
c'est ruquier qui t'encouragent et 1c
j'en ai parlé à laurent j'en ai parlé à
lucchini un jour on était au théâtre des
mathurins qui était vide il attendait
son public c'est à la salle était libre
pendant 45 minutes et je lui ai dit
qu'est ce que c'est et complètement fêlé
du temps pour sarah bernhardt es tu sûr
d'avoir une autonomie suffisante en
position verticale
droit qui est assis sur un canapé depuis
25 ans cave cay rue en ce moment c'est
la chasse aux vieux à la télé n'était
pas un perdreau de l'année
sur scène
je vais sérieusement tu es complètement
fou at on a tu vas en prendre plein la
gueule est-ce que la salle et les u18 l
aelies pendant une demi-heure des métaux
au fond fabrice il s'est mis au fond je
monte sur scène tu as des mâtures et mes
limites a pas de public n'a pas de décor
t'as pas de sont a pas de micro tech ont
bêtement fu chi likoud je commence je
vais te faire la première demi-heure de
mon stand up si au bout de cinq minutes
tu vois que j'ai un côté de la plaque
romain service je connais évidemment
longtemps rome - service
tu me fais ça et qui va pas je vais sur
scène cinq minutes dix minutes un quart
d'heure il est là 20 milliers de savigny
et là je m'arrête et pourquoi tu ta rage
il bascule derrière la glace il ya ton
public qui va rentrer il m'a dit tu vas
jouer avec tacatac qui voyait pas qu'il
décède et il m'a dit tu vas jouer dix
ans mais moi je pense qu'avec le succès
que tu as tu es parti pour la même
carrière qu'à la tête je dirais ce
serait extraordinaire et non mais
vraiment émerveillé parce que je vais
partout je vais un peu au liban dans 15
au canada tous les pays qui reçoivent
les émissions par tv5 monde me demande
de venir jouer et que les banques ne
crois pas qu'ils ont vu à ce lenard
comme ça
d'où son vélo la tournée non non non non
avec mon infirmière et la ville comme
monsieur hollande est venu voir ils
adhèrent et andré il a préféré ça à la
primaire de la gauche était un peu
surpris mais sa nourrice parce que je
l'inversé la courbe du chômage mon
ennemi c'est la finance il avait des
bonnes vannes hollande y aurait pu faire
du stand up pour lui dire des drôles la
politique way en tous les cas tout avait
promis de venir oui mais bien sûr je
viendrai voilà tu es le seul avec qui il
a tenu ses promesses parce que les
français sont très déçus de l'or
alors selon l'express françois hollande
vous aurait demandé des conseils pour
éduquer sa chienne rassurez moi il
parlait bien de son labrador
non c'était drôle hein ouais un soir
j'ai dîné avec lui avec son ami ouais et
puis il commença par les chiens avec ma
femme non c'est la passion il est
reparti avec des courses pour chiens
pendant oui françois hollande c'était
pour chiens des pensions
et maintenant nous passons à la question
sous serment
m
[Musique]
michel drucker
jurés vous de m'inviter sur le canapé
rouge mais oui mais le problème thirith
et qu' il ya plus vivement dimanche
d'après midi le canapé la carrière alors
quand ça va revenir évidemment je
delphine remet moi cette émission vrai
que laurent marti appel delphine met pas
sur le même ton que c'est une ex en plus
alors niche elle compte tenu de votre
état d'esprit en ce moment vous serez
pas étonné que je fasse une interview
lâcher prise
qu'est ce que vous avez toujours voulu
dire à l'antenne et que vous n'avez
jamais dit si on regarde bien mes
émissions depuis 53 ans parce que ça
fait cinquante trois ans je croise des
coûts 10 à travers mes émissions et je
pense que les gens ont fini par savoir
qui j'étais de [__] qu'est ce que vous
avez toujours voulu dire à votre chien
et que vous n'avez jamais dit je la
remercie infiniment de savoir tout sur
tout le monde et de rien des arrêts de
rien dire ce
qu'est ce que vous avez toujours voulu
dire oscar et que vous n'avez jamais dit
michel je voudrais dire aux stars
qui devraient prendre
mais la maison sur mon chien la
gratitude et la reconnaissance sont deux
maladies du chien non transmissible à
l'homme j'aimerais bien de temps en
temps mon chien les contamines bravo aux
as et
qu'est ce qui nous dit olivier à vos
parents et vous n'avez jamais dit
qu'ils m'ont bien gonflé mais je les
remercie aujourd'hui qu'est ce que vous
avez toujours voulu dire à thierry
ardisson et que vous n'avez jamais dit
tu feras jamaïcaine ap
c'est une question
mais tu réponds pas vraiment si la
vérité hommage répondre lorsque laurent
ruquier a pris ta place le samedi soir
est-ce que secrètement
tu a souhaité qu'il fasse moins bien
alors je vais être très franc avec toi
quand j'étais viré par carolis j'ai
pensé retour ensuite à stéphane bern
j'ai appelé stéphane et je lui ai dit
est ce que tu veux me remplacer puisque
moi je suis viré il m'a dit non ça
m'intéresse pas j'ai appelé laurent
sachant que laurent il avait déjà une
quotidienne c'est pour ça que je n'avais
pas appelé en premier parce qu'il
faisait déjà on a tout essayé que je
produisais j'ai installé laurent avec
plaisir parce que c'est un mec que
j'adore mais c'est vrai qu'une fois
qu'il a été installé
c'était dur de voir un mec qui est à ta
place et toi tu es à 19 heures sur canal
jean tout était bien meilleur que toi
hormis ciel qu'est ce que vous avez
toujours voulu dire à michel drucker et
vous n'avez jamais dit
nul de gruissan de son enfance comme l'a
si bien chanté jean ferrat quand est ce
qu enfin tu va couper les ponts avec
cette période de ta vie et quand est ce
que tu vas vraiment entrer dans l'âge
adulte et quand est ce que tu as oublié
c'est cette décennie qui me poursuit
depuis toujours celle où j'ai rien
appris rien lui rien retenu et je cours
après encore ces dix années que j'ai
perdus où j'ai rien foutu je mets ça
fait cinquante ans que j'essaie de les
rattraper ce qu'on va faire de toi voilà
michalon
là c'était l'intérêt j'étais grand chose
abel un peu
[Musique]
moi mon choix était un drame en sommes
de retour choquèrent toujours en
compagnie de michel drucker
merci
merci estonie dartus et dollars en asie
et maintenant nous passons à notre
invité politique de la semaine
[Musique]
virginie calmels sera bonsoir
vous êtes aujourd'hui première adjointe
au maire de bordeaux alain juppé
conseillère régionale de la nouvelle
acquis tels fondatrice de la droite
libre et vous soutenez françois fillon
mais avant ça vous avez été à 27 ans
directrice financière de numericable est
à 31 ans directrice générale déléguée de
canal+ à l'époque vous aviez la
réputation d'une executive woman sans
état d'âme la reine des plans sociaux
vous avez viré 660 salariés chez canal
vous avez déclaré
on a sort et on a sauvé ces entreprises
vous avez le clergé pas d'omelette sans
casser des oeufs je ne pense pas qu'on
puisse diriger dans la douce ce qui est
certain c'est que je crois qu'il faut
être juste et qu'en l'occurrence parfois
on prend des décisions difficiles quand
on est dirigeant n'a pas le choix ça
permet de sauver des entreprises ça
permet surtout de sauver les emplois et
de permettre à ces entreprises de
continuer à se développer et voiliers
sinon on serait pas là ce soir alors que
dire vie rejettent une femme de
caractère
avant jérôme chartier vous deviez vous
marier avec christian blanc ex pdg d'air
france et vous avait annulé le mariage
raté son vol quinze jours avant ce
pratiquement ça j'ai pas tellement pour
habitude de parler de ma vie privée mais
puisque vous le faites effectivement
c'est vous avez renvoyé les cadeaux oui
c'est vrai mais vous savez c'est d'abord
c'est une histoire personnelle donc
vous avez de christian blanc j'ai pas
forcément à les cadeaux et erding je
rappelle simplement qu'on avait un écart
d'âge important on avait près de 29 ans
d'écart d'âge et en l'occurrence on a
fait des valeurs on est restés très
proches j'ai beaucoup d'estimé de
respect pour lui mais j'ai estimé qu'il
fallait aussi être en adéquation avec ce
qu'on ressent profondément et en
l'occurence j'avais du cac on avait
décidé voilà ne pas donner suite à ce
mariage après canal vous devenez
directrice générale d'endemol france la
société qui a produit love story la stac
miss france secretstory de volz est à 41
ans j'ai directrice générale d'endemol
monde
1,5 milliard de chiffre d'affaires
présentes dans 31 pays
pendant la période endemol a mis en
place une charte de bonne conduite de la
télé réalité ça consistait en quoi
définir la taille minimum des strings
des candidates non c'était important de
rappeler la responsabilité que nous
avions et du coup je pensais que c'était
essentiel de rappeler qu'on avait des
règles à respecter
et ce code de bonne conduite avait pour
but de remettre en perspective un
certain nombre de choses qui n'étaient
pas à faire c'est vrai parce qu'après
les gens souvent les jeunes ils croivent
qu'on parle comme qu'il faut parler
comme ça et ça c'est pas bien l'armée et
vous avez raison notamment les fautes de
français des choses comme ça c'était des
choses importantes a rappelé les gros
mots à la télévision c'est parfait c'est
mon envie j'avais raison aux arrêts on
sait pas
alors virginie prime sam boss d'une
société est-ce qu'on peut coucher avec
son secrétaire ou c'est un privilège
réservé aux hommes goûtez moi ça m'est
jamais arrivé
c'est pas connu ni la promotion canapé
pour moi ni à l'envers voyez vous j'ai
jamais abusé à la budget la papesse de
la télé réalité mais c'est pas votre
came et après avoir versé 2 190 millions
d'euros à stéphane courbit
290 millions d'euros arthur 60 millions
d'euros à la gaffe 40 millions d'euros à
fogiel il vous reste rien pour nous on
n'était pas dans le bon franchement à ce
moment-là vous quitté endemol pour
entrer en politique avec alain juppé
vous rajeunissez alain juppé c'est vrai
il fait la couverture des inrocks
lab sur scène
tout est lui élu par ji qget un magazine
branché homme politique de l'année vous
avez des réseaux efficaces quand même
nom en l'occurence n'était pas du tout
en charge de la communication c'est vrai
en revanche parfois effectivement pour
10kg où ils m'ont appelé directement
c'est vrai que j'avais 5000 noms dans
notre répertoire un peu plus maintenant
parce qu'avec la politique vous savez ça
grossit fayos vous avez au dîner du
siècle oui c'est quoi 21 siècle où les
pauvres mercredi on sait pas ce que
c'est ça n'a rien à voir avec la
richesse rassurez moi y'a pas d'ouvriers
au dîner du siècle je ne crois pas mais
en tout cas le si vous voulez le le mode
de sélection et d'avoir fait quelque
chose dans un domaine qui soit peut être
un peu reconnus via des rappeurs au
dîner du siècle
je prends pas en avoir croisé mais ça
manque alors sérieusement c'est quoi la
différence entre la télé réalité la
politique quand je dirigeais endemol
vous savez moi je n'étais pas
productrice je suis incapable de
produire une émission mais je dirigeais
des équipes et surtout il y avait
beaucoup de gestion de crise et là je
peux vous assurer que dans la politique
on et services les portes à dire qu'il
faut des nerfs il faut de la résistance
au stress il faut beaucoup travailler et
puis on est aussi beaucoup sous le joug
des médias ce qu'on retrouve en
politique alors alain juppé était favori
à la primaire de la droite et pour les
médias il est déjà président de la
république est là
[Musique]
ces filles en qui gagnent
alors est ce que vous n'avez pas trop
boboïsée
gauchisé juppé pour des électeurs qui
finalement voulait un mec de droite pure
et dure comme fillon vous savez ce qui
est intéressant c'est qu'en politique il
ya beaucoup de l'image et quand vous
regardez le projet d'alain juppé ou
pouvant regarder le projet de françois
fillon ils sont très très proches et
après c'est une question d'incarnation
d'image vous qui connaissez très bien
notre métier la télévision vous pensez
que ça s'est joué à la télé oui beaucoup
je le crois je crois que ça s'est
beaucoup joué à la télévision ça s'est
beaucoup joué dans les dernières la
lettre dernière ligne droit année dans
les débats notamment et c'est vrai que
alain juppé a eu dans son entourage des
personnes qui lui conseillé d'être
plutôt en retrait parce qu'il avait une
très large avance dans les sondages du
coup il n'a pas été très combatif il a
été plus court un peu fond de court est
effectivement l'image a été aussi
importante
malheureusement deux ans ou pendant deux
ans il était sur le terrain il était
très largement leader et ou franchement
les français avaient envie de ce que
alain juppé à porter mais c'est vrai que
l'image a été clé quand on vous pose une
question on fait toujours des réponses
de 20 minutes au parfois
alors aujourd'hui virginie vous soutenez
françois fillon
j'imagine que s'il est élu il vous
donnera un job génial et bien payé style
assistante parlementaire
alors vous êtes en et françois fillon
avec la fois des nouveaux convertis vous
m'expliquer le 14 février sur france
inter que l'argent touché par p
l'appuyons aurait pu être touché par
madame dupont et que c'est pas plus
d'argent public dépensées là vous
regretter de l'avoir dit ça non mais
vous savez d'abord je ne suis pas une
communicante j'ai dirigé un certain
nombre de sociétés comme vous le
rappeliez dans le domaine des meilleurs
que la communication était mon métier
donc je peux commettre des maladresses
de communication et notamment parfois
essayé d'avoir des j'ai pas le talent de
baffie et cette capacité à avoir fait
recours à ces recours et est très
dense et oui après celle du monde à
jouir
alors ensuite j'ai comparé le 8 février
sur lcp les sommes perçues par pénélope
fillon à celle que reçoit le canard
enchaîné au petit des aides à la presse
sauf que canard enchaîné il touche pas
d'argent dans la presse à part apple
quoi c'est parce que alors je n'ai pas
comparé ce deux choses qui sont
totalement incomparables j'ai simplement
dit qu'il fallait pas qu'on soit dupe et
que x 20 ans des sommes ça fait des
grognons bah oui j'ai fait des millions
pour madame fillon mais y compris pour
le canard enchaîné si on prend les aides
indirectes qu'ils perçoivent et ils
perçoivent 500000 euros à peu près des
d'un direct sur 20 ans ça fait beaucoup
d'argent pour les contribuables alors je
n'ai en fait les gens n'ont pas été
choqué que françois fillon est engagé sa
femme comme assistante parlementaire ce
qui a choqué les gens c'est que c'était
un emploi fictif mais vous savez moi je
fais confiance à notre candidat françois
fillon il n'y a que lui aujourd'hui qui
soit capable de dire ce que madame
pénélope fillon a réellement fait mais
pourquoi parce que c'est sa femme se
serait forcément un emploi fictif après
jeunes une fois encore moi je ne suis ni
juge ni procureur ni avocat dans cette
affaire ce que je veux simplement dire
c'est que je ne m'en remets à ce que
françois fillon a dit c'est à dire que
lui a considéré que sa femme travaillait
pour lui et je suis convaincu qu'elle a
dû lui être très utile et c'est sûrement
pour cela qu'il a rémunéré elle plutôt
que quelqu'un d'autre parce que de toute
façon cet argent il serait allé à une
autre attaché parlementaire est ce que
françois fillon c'est que le rôle de
première dame de france n'est pas
rémunéré
en
suivant ton petit bout de bonheur
nevers se tuent jamais en tout bien tout
honneur de jolis pensée inter vergil
j'ai fondé droite libre ça passe mieux
qu libéral en france c'est un peu un
gros mot alors vous êtes obligés de
rajouter c'est un mouvement libéral
humani qu'il faut rajouter humaniste
c'est qu'au départ libéral ça fait peur
aux gens mais malheureusement passe
alors une fois encore on serait aux
états unis on se poserait pas la
question on penserait que la seule façon
de résoudre le problème du chômage c'est
le libéralisme économique qu'en france
pour les jo dans le libéralisme
humaniste c'est chacun pour sa gueule
avec une petite tape sur l'épaule non
c'est vraiment pas ça c'est au contraire
comment on essaye de re créer de la
richesse dans ce pays qui bénéficient au
plus grand nombre et je pense notamment
aux jeunes qui sont les laissés pour
compte de la politique depuis trop
longtemps alors la droite libre c'est un
missile anti macron visite mc ren est
une imposture pas question de lui
laisser le monopole de la modernité oui
du progressisme moi ça me choque qu'on
croit que la droite serait le refuge de
tous les conservatismes
il ya des gens qui sont progressistes et
qui sont de droite elle est sympa et
allons faire est marié avec elle sa
vache rit oui je trouve que ce matin ça
allait très bien 14 heures j'ai croisé
mâle il ya un problème parce qu'elle
rêvait diabète et après elle m'a dit oui
je me sens très tard alors virginie vous
dont le père était viticulteur en
algérie à oran vous avez dû adorer la
phrase d'emmanuel macron la colonisation
est un crime contre l'humanité oui c'est
un beau père est un criminel vous savez
ça en tant que fille de pieds-noirs et
pour tous ceux qui ont connu cette
période de l'histoire en plus doubler
parce que macron il fait pas une
boulette il en fait deux je vous ai
compris la phrase mais la quête de good
la cour a empilé les pieds noirs parce
qu'elle voulait non je vous ai compris
sauf qu'en fait il est en train de faire
l'algérie a un moment faut arrêter mais
c'est une double son nom les bornes ont
arrêté mon histoire de l'afrique comment
la situation qui a en afrique en ce
moment ne correspond pas tout ce que
vous dites depuis tout à l'heure la
dépendance de la france par rapport à
l'afrique l'histoire de la colonisation
le commerce triangulaire et tout ce qui
s'ensuit on a enlevé par placements par
fdl ça existe y en a une racine quelque
part ainsi il n'y a pas eu quelque chose
de fait la presse à un problème en tant
que français la cij tavini par rapport à
ça on ne reconnaît pas forcément ce qui
s'est passé dans l'histoire par rapport
à tous ces pays là si on à piller
l'afrique ont l'appui encore
jusqu'aujourd'hui vous savez que le
franc cfa lefranc africa et
jusqu'aujourd'hui fait en france c'est
encore la france qui décide de quel
argent va donner à l'afrique yeux mais à
un moment tu donc tous les beaux
discours et c'est qu'on entend tous les
jours c'est bien beau la vie d'un moment
ça va
la blanche un peu
je me permets succès l'espère à la
colonisation je pense qu emmanuel macron
pourrait aussi faire preuve de plus de
subtilité dans son discours parce que
vous savez ces façons moi que ça n'en a
pas vu dans l'âme
si vous me permettez juste de faire
baver dans le volet non c'est des
amalgames dire que la colonisation c'est
un crime contre l'humanité pour moi oui
je comprends que nous ne soyons pas
d'accord et je respecte que nous ne
soyons pas d'accord pour nous rejoindre
le top une insulte c'est une insulte à d
et noir c'est une insulte à des harkis
quand il savait pas que les pénuries
grande partie d'afrique et bien sûr mais
vous savez là encore ne faisons pas
d'amalgamé
l'adil vous savez il faut se comparer
aussi la colonisation française peut se
s'enorgueillir d'avoir aussi dans ces
pays apportez des jongles et c'est bien
normal voyagistes c'est pas apporter
c'est un débat au sénat
je pense que je vais pas une bande de
sauvages qui était dans mes poches le
continent je pense qu'il ya plusieurs
volets la vienne vous l'esprit qu'elle a
donnée à l'afrique donc pour moi est ce
que la mairie lui disait sans un détour
chez ake les trois vagues j'ai dit
ghannouchi que les escales vaches et des
chèvres la colonisation c'est des
chaînes mentales culturel
non mais
chris perrais a été je pense que je
pense que vous y gagnerez et notamment
les politiques je suis vous regardez ce
que fait jean louis borloo par exemple
il est très attaché il passe beaucoup de
temps à l'électrification en afrique
vous avez beaucoup dépensé ils sont au
contraire très attaché à aider le
développement en afrique parce que ça
vous pensez que les laisser faire leur
monnaie les laisser filer les laisser
faire leur propre argent les laisser
négocier leurs matières premières avec
avec dans les dents dans dans les bons
prix les laisser se débrouiller un peu
par eux mêmes peut penser que ça les
aide pas plus que leur apporter de
l'électricité ou un peu de lumière
c'est un non sens pour nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je m'égare
james grenoble a comme drogue et
maintenant
justement on passe à nos quêtes et ou de
la semaine
m
jean
alors placier se tenir bonsoir tout le
monde connaît ça
enfin les kangourous l'argent de guerre
et de sexe à la télé tout le monde
connaît sa main
[Musique]
m
mais qui se souvient du ministère
moi je m'en souviens le premier groupe
de rap français
100% noir que vous avez fondé au début
des années 90 à l'époque on en vient à
notre sujet finalement vous croyez une
révolution noire vous dites nous étions
de vrais militants notre inspiration
c'était malcom x martin 9 hacking et
frantz fanon lui quand elle avait 15 ans
se demander quel allait être notre
avenir et on se disait mais c'est pas
possible on n'a pas d'avenir je peux pas
être ça je peux pas être ça on dirait
que tout et tout est sclérosé et on
avait envie de crier ministère amer
c'est un vrai cri je pense que ce cri
qu'on a on voyait dans le rap par
rapport à cette situation par rapport à
ce qui se passait aussi en banlieue
voilà aujourd'hui regardés en personne
n'a entendu secret à l'époque déjà c'est
en 1992 que vous sortez votre premier
album pourquoi tant de haine dans cet
album il ya un morceau intitulé
brigitte femme de flic c'est l'histoire
d'une femme de crs qui fréquent cds car
dans les caves de hmg une histoire vraie
c'est une histoire d'amour surtout way
après c'est vrai ouais c'est brigitte
femme de flic ça vraiment existé ya
vraiment une une femme de séez qui
avaient des aventures à gaver les
aventures de nascar dans la cave de la
cité le morceau tombe dans l'oreille
d'un crs toulousain qui prévient charles
pasqua charles pasqua essaie de faire
interdire la chanson mais le délai de
prescription est passé a dit un jour à
jour c'était chaud pour nous
[Musique]
m
parti ceci étant vous êtes désormais
dans le collimateur des flics et les
problèmes arrivent vraiment avec un
morceau intitulé sacrifice de poulet en
1995 dans le concept album qui
accompagne sortie du film khassawneh la
haine sacrifice de poulet
[Musique]
pas de plus
alors sacrifice de poulet je vous dit je
suis ça parlait pas des restaurants kfc
oui en fait le sujet c'était
il ya des problèmes entre il ya eu une
bavure et des problèmes entre les jeunes
et la police et nous c'est un peu comme
une sorte de ré de réalisation nous on a
voulu placer la caméra parler des
émeutiers et faire ressentir un petit
peu ce qui se passe dans cette émeute ce
qui se passe là dedans et voilà c'est
pour ça que ce titre était fait alors à
l'époque la ministre de l'intérieur qui
est jean louis debré porte plainte vous
êtes condamné à 250 mille francs
d'amendé
et moi je suis attaqué aussi en tant que
directeur du magazine entrevue ou votre
mentor kenzy déclare on dit sur votre
disque qu'il faut aller brûler un
commissariat et sacrifiés du poulet quoi
de plus normal et là on va ensemble chez
le juge
[Musique]
jamais de troisième album du ministère
amer vous dites on était plus en accord
avec nos carrières solo quand on sortait
on était vu comme des pères noël noir
les enfants crier nos prénoms toi qu'a
dit ça parce qu'on est revenue le
ministère amour moi si tu veux au début
qu'on avait une carte solo pour nous
c'était des récréations c'était les
vacances des ministres et on pensait pas
trop car sur l'eau allait faire voilà ce
gros succès là donc on a été dépassé à
prendre n'aurait pas pu revenir à faire
la troisième savoir et schizophrène
schizophrène et en os alors quand même
contrairement à votre pote doc gynéco
vous n'êtes pas les soutenir nicolas
sarkozy quand même disons que moi cette
histoire de doc gynéco qui soutient
nicolas sarkozy moi c'est pas ça le
problème moi je trouve que un mec sorti
de nulle part qui au final bout de
salles de son travail se retrouve à côté
du président c'est que quand même eu un
mérite quelque part moi c'est sur son
discours c'est juste sur le discours
qu'il a eu la vie un discours les
banlieusards des clowns etc je pense que
c'est là qu'il a dit que les mecs de
banlieue c'était dévoila ou un truc
comme ça je pense que c'est là qu'il
s'est planté en plus deux jours avant on
m'avait appelé et m'a dit vas y fais
attention ton pote il va soutenir
sarkozy ouais on était on était en train
de faire les nrj music awards avec
johnny hallyday attend répétition jeudi
à bruno benoit c'est vrai qu'il va
supplanter sarkozy mais non c'est pas
vrai boost un bide et économique alors
il serait qu'un album qui s'appelle
double pennec et jamais sortir quoi un
album en hébreu n'était même pas un
album très funky très gros big to fail
jamais sorti l'album ce que j'étais je
dis très bien j'étais c'est ça des
musiques et bruno était chez virgin donc
se sont pas attardés sur la maison des
secrets donc aujourd'hui après des
carrières solo à succès vous revenez sur
scène 20 ans après pour la tournée l'âge
d'or durable dans tous les zénith de
france à partir du 3 mars le 27 mars
vous serez à l'accord hôtel arena il ya
un double album chez warner le 3 mars
c'est exactement double album avec
quelques grands titres de l'est pas mais
alors il ya nenê team eg marrant les
sages poètes de la rue fayette a été un
des premiers à inviter des rappeurs
français oui johnny reid est reitman
ouais merci
[Musique]
gecas à l'offre
la plus large et des ministères par le
site r&d s'afficher sous les barrières
et les passages étaient gérables
faire c'est rester toujours passionnés
ces questions
[Musique]
pas
[Applaudissements]
le 27 mars donc au popb
c'est compliqué de faire du rap à l'âge
où on se fait dépister du cancer de la
prostate
mais nous ce qui est bien c'est que deux
parmi la première génération ont été les
plus jeunes donc là je cache pas il a 44
ans et ça va pour l'instant ça va danser
les gens plus âgés que nous qui connaît
et on va aujourd'hui ça serait plutôt je
fais l'amour à ta maman que je nique ta
mère
aujourd'hui c'est bien les choses
sacrifice de poulet
ça vous évoque surtout les barbecue en
famille non
moi je suis devenu végétalien depuis le
mois d'avril dans les normes je mange
peu de poulet alors maintenant on va
faire un truc donc on va faire le bilan
de ce qui s'est passé jusque là le bilan
[Musique]
changé
vite
chaque instant par des histoires d'avant
conditions alors michel drucker
jusqu'ici
ça va très bien est ce qu'il ya des
choses que vous regrettez d'avoir dit
tout des choses que vous regrettez de ne
pas avoir dit non non j'étais très bien
j'étais très heureux mais c'était très
bien vrai puis le contraire j'ai
l'impression que la dernière fois que je
suis venu ici et il ya deux ans et j'ai
l'impression qu'en deux ans j'ai changé
tu as beaucoup changé plus ça va plus on
t'aime
tu viens tu sais quoi
devient universelle
virginie escales des choses que vous
savez n'est pas dit non ce que je
regrette c'est pas être aussi concise
qu'elle souhaite rêva fille non mais
sérieusement non je crois que si je
parle à peine de m'appeler après
l'émission dit le maintenant c'est
intéressant de pouvoir avoir des
échanges on ici vous savez c'est aussi
ça la politique moi j'ai beaucoup de
respect pour les gens qui ont des vraies
convictions ce que je n'aime pas c'est
ce qu' il louvoie qui sont cyniques qui
joue une mi temps dans chaque camp ou
qu'ils n'adhèrent pas à des vraies
convictions parfois on ne peut ne pas
être d'accord on n'a pas la même
histoire moi je suis fille de pieds
noirs nous comme vous le dites vous avez
une double nationalité déjà ça veut dire
qu'on a forcément un prisme déformant du
danger tenace du nord au sud des açores
c'est bien sûr mais voyez mon compagnon
et député de sarcelles et s'appelle
jérôme chartier et en l'occurrence les
il est très présent et il est très à
l'écouté je crois que c'est important ce
que j'ai ce que je n'aurais pas dit mais
c'est tout ce que j'ai aimé c'est de
vous dire qu'effectivement les
échangeant ses riches etc ça à mon avis
qui fait la force aussi du débat public
et politique
est-ce qui a détruit que t'as pas dit ou
tu as envie de dire ou non non je viens
mais après l'émission à moi j'ai
rencontré des gens dont j'étais fan et
j'ai rencontré vite d'autres dont je
pense que je serai moins fan mais mais
voilà en tout cas
dsk voilà j'étais à la maison avec
l'autre alors pas si l'économie
maintenant reste là tu ne viens pas
d'âme non non on a des choses à dire en
quoi encore en bêta qui vient après et
jusqu'ici ça va ouais mais on est bien
laurent j'avais plein de choses à dire
mais virgin et à utiliser tout le temps
de parole dont charles munger
et voilà c'est une opinion
michel drucker je vais vous libérer
parce qu'il faut que vous alliez vous
coucher maintenant alors demande
vivement dimanche prochain avec nicolas
bedos et tu auras acier et le film est
exceptionnel
michel merci d'avoir été avec nous c'est
nb200 et on se retrouve après l'appel à
tous
[Musique]
au mont saint loup terrier rang bonsoir
les terriens sonne le retour sur terre
toujours en compagnie de virginie
calmels
cassis et scanner
dartus
deux ans ma fille
est maintenant mesdames messieurs c'est
l'heure de grille en 2017
[Musique]
ces femmes on commence par une nouvelle
judiciaire alexandre balkany
emprisonné pour ne pas avoir payé la
totalité de sa caution
pour ses parents pour isabelle et
patrick ça doit être une fierté immense
vous vous rendez compte le père 40 ans
de ma douce de triche au plus haut
niveau un casier judiciaire long comme
le bras cette mise en examen il n'a
jamais été en prison il est toujours
député toute sa vie le gars bafoué les
autorités commis les pires exactions
s'est même fait sucer en menaçant une
fille avec un flingue et là c'est son
fils alexandre 36 ans à peine qui est en
tôle qui sauve l'honneur de la famille
chaque fois l'excellent
peut-être mettre des trucs là les urnes
pour voter dans les prisons cela son
projet ce qui permettrait à alexandre
éventuellement de voter pour la
réélection de son père
le monde va bien
payé 200 mille euros par axa alors qu'il
était parlementaire françois fillon se
retrouve en plein conflit d'intérêts on
s'en fout on s'en fout quoi qu'il ait
fait on sait qu'il est pourri jusqu'à
l'os et qu'il ira jusqu'au bout alors
maintenant quoi qu'on apprenne de plus
qu'il est un compte en suisse avec
cahuzac piquer des enveloppes de liquide
avec claude guéant partouzer au carlton
de lille avec dsk montre s habitat des
écolos avec denis baupin on s'en fout on
sait qu'il ira jusqu'au bout
[Applaudissements]
le parquet de nanterre lance une enquête
pour fraude fiscale contre thierry
solère le porte parole de françois
fillon thierry solère qui a le même
orthophoniste que dominique besnehard a
tenu à s'expliquer écoutez j'assume
totalement les faits qui me sont
reprochés
j'ai effectivement truander les impôts
falsifiés ma déclaration entre 2012 et
2013 je représente aujourd'hui françois
fillon et donc par fidélité parra
tassement pas loyalisme je devais aussi
être un voyou un depuis la nuit des
temps tous les escrocs sont accompagnées
d'un lieutenant mairie n'avait françois
bès al capone frank nitti emile buisson
rené lacabe françois fillon à thierry
solère je revendique totalement ce
statut
le député républicain claude goasguen
conseils à françois fillon de se la
jouer à la donald trump ah ouais c'est
ça la solution pour gagner bon ils sont
déjà pas mal de points communs à trump
et fillon ils vomissent tous les deux
sur la presse et son copain avec poutine
ils veulent détruire le système de santé
ils sont mouillés dans des conflits
d'intérêts
faux pts et que françois fillon déclare
lui aussi qu'il attrape les femmes par
la chatte c'est peut-être ça le petit
truc qui lui manque
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jean vincent placé s'engage pour benoît
hamon a aux [__] mer
il peut pas refuser benoît hamon mais
c'est arrivé comment hier soir il était
tranquille chez lui et là il ya
quelqu'un qui tapait les kits annonce la
nouvelle jean vincent placé de soutien
aux [__] peut pas refuser
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nicolas sarkozy retrouve un travail
ouais
[Applaudissements]
l'ancien président a été engagé par le
groupe hôtelier accor hôtel un groupe
qui comprend ibis mercure novotel
sofitel et pullman nicolas sarkozy dans
l'hôtellerie il va faire un malheur
oui bonjour
c'est nicolas sarkozy
écoutez je peux vous proposer suites
junior à l'hôtel pullman avec wifi
gratuit espace bureau écran plat 42
pouces salle de bains baignoire mini bar
coffre fort plateau de courtoisie
rafraîchissement discrétion avec un lit
king size et une double couette platinum
160 duvet d'oie et vous pouvez faire
tous les hôtels de la région au niveau
de l'accueil du confort de la qualité
y'a pas mieux maintenant je veux dire
une chose 1 si vous voulez une
chauve-souris ali dure comme du bois
passé une nuit blanche côté les moutons
avoir des courants d'air une douche qui
fuit et le gap du dessus qu'on entend
quand il va pisser vous réservé à la
concurrence chez campanile première
classe au best western
ici vous êtes choyé chouchouter si vous
payez en liquide ses 25 % de réduction
je veux bien changer de métier mais pas
mes habitudes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
furieux de ne pas avoir été invité par
tf1 à sa grande soirée présidentiel
nicolas dupont aignan parle de viol
démocratique le
viol démocratique c'est très douloureux
c'est pour vous mais une marianne un bus
entier dans dans le rectum c'est plus
douloureux qu une matraque donc
on pense très fort du poignant
[Applaudissements]
le discours de gilbert collard aux
assises du front national interrompu par
son téléphone dont la sonnerie et la
marseillaise de gainsbourg c'est pour ne
pas avoir l'air d'un vieux con at il
déclaré ce sera pas suffisant
contrôle de police litigieux à lille au
lieu de rendre son portable à une
personne qu'il venait de contrôler le
policier jette le téléphone par dessus
une balustrade
non non dans le cul de la personne
contrôlée le portable
qu'est-ce qu'on vous apprend dans les
écoles de police le portable dans le cul
et après on le fait sonner sur vibreur
c'est ça qui est marrant on n'est plus
protégé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
suite à une épidémie de grippe aviaire
tous les canards des langues vont être
abattus à vis à pamela anderson mélanie
griffith mais griam donatella versace
jocelyne wild einstein éviter d'aller
dans les landes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pierre bellemare confirme il
enregistrait bien ces histoires tout nu
morandini c'est le contraire il fallait
se déshabiller pour lui raconter une
histoire
on termine par un hommage au grand
journal l'émission emblématique de
canal+ créé par michel denisot il ya 13
ans s'arrête définitivement le 3 mars
prochain avec l'arrêt du grand journal
canal+ met fin à une longue tradition de
tokyo sur sa chaîne trente ans de
spectacle ébouriffant de séquences
cultes qui ont révélé d'innombrables
talents antoine de coach josé garcia
benoît poelvoorde edouard baer jamel
debbouze françois morel charlotte le bon
yann barthès omar sy et tant d'autres
temps d'autres des sketches d'anthologie
les nuls les guignols le sav les
deschiens monsieur manatane les robins
des bois mais ne soyons pas triste le
spectacle continue pour cela il suffit
de passer sur s'est vite pour retrouver
tous les soirs joie et bonne humeur avec
gilles verdez enora malagré capucine
manager qu'est ce qu'elle dit sébastien
cauet matthieu delormeau et tendance ne
soyons pas triste la relève est assurée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
gfr
audition sur ces 8
et maintenant on passe à la battle des
idées du championnat un bègue
et c'est evans officier de police
judiciaire dans les yvelines et steve
hill gustave conseiller municipal à
brétigny sur orge que nous acquérons sur
ce plateau après le magnéto battle de ce
soir vers la guerre civile
[Musique]
les tensions entre la police et les
jeunes de banlieue c'est pas nouveau 10
95 cv rappeur du ministère amer sont
passés au tribunal pour leur chanson
sacrifice de poulet était sur la bo de
la n2 kassovitz
[Musique]
le fils de comparer la situation des
banlieues à l'histoire du gars qui tombe
d'un gratte ciel et qui à chaque étage
de sa chute se rassure en se disant
jusqu'ici tout va bien important je fais
pas la chute
c'est l'atterrissage pour connaître que
c'était prémonitoire 22 ans plus tard la
chute continue et la haine devient
palpable entre la police et les jeunes
des quartiers malgré l'appel au calme
lancé par théo et la famille
des manifestations de soutien ont
souvent dégénéré
[Applaudissements]
au début on dénonce les violences
policières pour rappel la mort de la da
mata aurait tué par des gendarmes l'an
dernier lors d'une interpellation
et puis souvent la colère est si forte
qu'une partie des manifestants
s'attaquent à la police ou alors mais ce
véhicule des médias
cela dit on se demande parfois de quel
côté bien vraiment la haine dont un
syndicaliste de la police affirme que
traiter un noir de [__] est pas
vraiment raciste les aventures de
[__] un jour je m'appelle pas au
bout il ya de quoi s'inquiéter sur
l'état d'esprit qui règne dans les
commissariats
[Musique]
d'ailleurs il y en a qui s'inquiète la
semaine dernière l'idée publié une
pétition contre les violences policières
signé par des dizaines d'artistes
l'occasion aussi de publier le texte
d'un élu de brétigny steevy gustave y
dénonce l'infiltration de la police par
des jeunes d'extrême droite qui
profiteraient de l'uniforme pour conny
sur les noirs et les arabes la direction
de la police a bien sûr protester
n'empêche en 2012 30% des policiers
voter fn aujourd'hui ils sont plus de
50% venir qu'ils sont confrontés à la
montée de la violence comme pour les
policiers brûlé à viry châtillon et puis
aussi à la montée de l'islam radical
comme lors de l'assassinât du couple de
policiers à magnanville en plus les
syndicats sont débordés par la colère de
la base et organiser des manifestations
illégales l'an dernier
on a donc des policiers énervés face à
des jeunes à leysin colère tout ça sur
fond de montée du fn et l'islam radical
la situation banlieue est de plus
explosive que tu dirais maintenant d'une
étincelle pour provoquer de nouvelles
émeutes comme en 2005
s'était dit le blaco mise en image de
julien gracq
bonsoir jadot fiscaux ni judiciaire dans
les yvelines bienvenue parmi le
butin bon soir y est conseiller
municipal à brétigny sur orge dans
l'essonne bienvenue parmi nous alors
qu'ils jettent fils de militaire votre
père est mort pour la france en service
commandé à djibouti
vous êtes ancien champion de hip hop et
aujourd'hui conseiller municipal divers
gauche de brétigny sur orge dans
l'essonne
en réaction la ferté au vous est publiée
dans libération le 15 février une
tribune intitulée lettre d'un élu de la
république à l'avenir vous vous dites
que la police nationale est complètement
noyautée par des jeunes militants fn qui
profitent de l'uniforme pour pouvoir
commettre des exactions en toute
impunité vous dites ces agents du
désordre sont des brebis galeuses
on les reconnaît à leur cri de [__]
[__] biko [__] [__] ce texte
a été signé par de nombreuses
personnalités dont pas si ces présents
regardez cette photo donc c'était le
week-end dernier sacrifiant le poulet
c'est à dire que c'est toujours
d'actualité
alors françois fillon a dit que le
ministère de l'intérieur devrait porter
plainte contre les auteurs de cette
tribune pour quoi tu penses qu'on vit
dans un état de droit et qu'il faut
respecter les forces de l'ordre ce que
je constate c'est que la police comme
les gendarmes d'ailleurs sont
extrêmement rigoureux et condamne très
fortement dans leurs propres rangs ce
que vous appelez les brebis galeuses est
tant mieux parce que évidemment quand on
porte un uniforme on se doit d'être à la
hauteur de cet uniforme mais ils sont
très fortement condamné et donc il ne
faut pas dire que on est anti flics en
tout cas moi je considère qu'on a besoin
des forces de l'ordre dans ce pays ces
promenades pour vous dire que la police
est gangrené par le fn est une connerie
il n'y a pas plus de raciste dans la
police que dans la société française en
moyenne et les émeutes de 2017 par
rapport aux émeutes de 2005 les
émeutiers sont quand même dit vous
beaucoup plus jeune et beaucoup mieux
organisée qu'à l'époque tout à fait tout
à fait alors plus juste rappeler ici que
la police nationale est constituée de
femmes et d'hommes qui s'engage pour la
nation qui s'engage pour la sécurité des
français il n'y a pas plus de raciste
dans la police nationale que ailleurs
quand on écrit et quand on est élu de la
république et qu'on écrit une tribune
dans libération
insistant sur le fait que la police
nationale recrute des racistes c'est
scandaleux honteux et jeu
rend pas pourquoi aujourd'hui le
ministère de l'intérieur n'a pas saisi
la justice sur cette tribune je la
tribune de style tout à fait cette
tribune la emmène plus d'huile sur le
feu quel n'apaise vraiment cher steve et
alors qu'est ce que vous en pensez à
vous y répondre les gens n'ont pas lu
ses tribunes policiers et raciste c'est
antinomique pour moi donc je le fais en
aucun cas d' amalgame plusieurs fois
dans la tribune jeudi une minorité ne
sera jamais une majorité j'ai fait cette
tribune en tant que citoyen français en
tant que pupille de la nation dans mon
père a donné sa vie à vie pour la france
il est élevé dans des casernes avec des
grades avec le avec la levée du drapeau
avec le le mon père me disait quand
j'étais plus jeune il faut faire deux
fois plus que les autres donc très
longtemps je me suis dit mais c'est qui
les autres est ce que c'est parce que je
suis noir enfin métis et ce truc est un
an le common comme ma mère mais elle m'a
expliqué que deux fois plus que les
autres c'est parce qu'il était militaire
et qu'il fallait respecter l'uniforme
j'ai toujours respecté les uniformes en
terminant cette tribune avant d'envoyer
à libé je me suis dit je vais avoir tout
les mecs du quartier qui vont être
contre moi parce que je fais une
distinction entre les brebis galeuses et
les policiers et j'ai donc j'ai vu cette
tribune à des amis policiers et ceux et
ce terme de brebis galeuses monsieur le
policier c'est des policiers qui m'ont
donné qu'ils m'ont dit nous quand on est
en service quand on va dans des zones
très dur si on a une brebis galeuse avec
nous qui va traité de [__] de [__]
de ou de blanc ou de blanc aussi parce
que le racisme n'est pas qu'un racisme
sur les noirs et sur les arabes ils nous
mettent en danger il jette l'opprobre
sur toute la fonction de police stéphane
on utilise des mots là ce soir que moi
qui me révolte infiltrez vous vous
rendez compte du move vous utilisez de
parler par l'avocat vos collègues
monsieur moi moi les gens me disent il
ya des gens quand ils sont en service à
l'intérieur ils dénoncent non parce que
je voudrais juste qu'on rappelle une
histoire de trois policiers antilles est
qui qui leur capitaine les appeler
[__] si ils ont porté plainte contre
leur hiérarchie ça a mis du temps ils
ont gagné deux de ces policiers ont été
mutés et ce jeune policier guadeloupéen
qui a voulu rester en disant je
représente la france c'est mon pays on a
continué à lui dire des insultes
racistes le racisme n'est pas une
opinion c'est un délit ce jeune policier
ce jeune guadeloupéen s'est suicidé donc
ça existe monsieur arrêtez avec fédérer
jamais dit que j'arrêtais avec le déni
je parle jamais des cas d'asie s'étaient
pas je parle de ses brebis galeuses
ancien général et qu'elle général ils
ont été lancées a admis avec des
policiers non non oui c'est pas un peu
délaissé leur moi je connais moins de 6
mois et 5 ans et voilà c'est plus c'est
bon entre lecture d'asie j'ai vu une
statistique comme quoi quand même
pourcentage de policiers voter voter
front national
trop d'entre eux annonce 50
et alors ça veut dire quoi monsieur
savez ce que ça veut dire que la police
nationale
je m'énerve quand on regarde vous dites
oui s'investit que vous me laisser finir
de parler vous fait marcher les chiffres
même si c'est pas le langage est pas bon
maintenant je vais vous écouter mais
nous il est question j'aimerais pas pu
me poser la question vous orienter
donnant dire que la police nationale je
parlais racisme et il ya 50% de
fonctionnaires de police et qu'ils
votent front national quand il ya plein
de gens autour de nous on a tout ce
qu'on dit a plein d'amis certains sont
engagés dans la police on a tous besoin
de la police on a besoin on est dans un
état de droit vivre dans un état sans
flics c'est pas possible personne n'en
rêvent de voir le travail des policiers
on l'a tous applaudi quand les policiers
font font un vrai travail on est
derrière eux mais quand il ya ba vue on
est dans un état de droit on a droit
d'échanger des idées etc y'a pas de
problème excusé quand il ya quelqu'un
qui franchit la ligne vous nous donnez
appelé tous les jours donc quand ça
arrive chez vous à vous de faire ce que
vous m'avez entendre qu'on issus de mon
ado là à parler est ce que vous n'avez
on a besoin de la police on a besoin
d'une vraie pour je suis d'abord et je
monte mes de nettoyer un petit peu ce
que fait jour à damas pour neo pour tous
ces cas là chaque fois le message envoyé
par rapport à la jeunesse a toujours été
un message d'impunité d'une certaine
manière mais non monsieur d'une certaine
manière je dessine je donne mon point de
vue jean danjou autant critique pas tout
tous les poules la police nationale font
les le global des courriers le plus
contrôlé
j'ai fini le plus contrôlé dans ce pays
ce tome i jean pensez quoi pour moi le
vrai discours de fond s'est restructurée
l'entrée à l'école de police écoutez
comment d'assaut comment cela se fait-il
que pour être avocat il faut au minimum
7 ans d'études pour devenir policier ah
non avec les vacances suis moins en huit
mois - exane 500 c'est inacceptable il
est noir donc pour mémoire tellement
raison le métier de policier est un
métier est mal payé où les gens sont mal
formés et mal éclairé malformés moi le
mal considérés et certainement de mal
encadré on reconnaît des policiers donc
on parle pas là on vous parle c'est pas
c'est pas le passé des deux comiques de
17 ans 18 ans donc on sait comment ça se
passe donc il ya des amis policiers qui
nous disent que même dans leur école de
police y avait des psychopathes a vécu
une autre à 6 dès dvd et c'est cela dont
je parle voilà uniquement dont monsieur
donc sa ligne de fond une balle de match
il faut faire au mieux les former et
faut leur donner plus de moyens parce
que les policiers qui sont mutés qui
mène de province on les jette en
banlieue son ex inexpérimentés il arrive
on leur fait signer lui 8 ans minimum
dans les banlieues ils arrivent ils sont
en sous-effectif il arrive dans les
banlieues sont comme ça ils voient 50
lascars devant eux alors qu'ils sont 10
ou 5 voilà dos répond on va avoir un
vrai discours de vincent répond stéphane
depuis la sphère de viry-châtillon
rappelle quand même qu'on a des
collègues qui ont été brûlées bien un
par des voyous par des voyous il a le
collègue justement parce que vous vous
connaissez le prénom au passage c'est
vincent masingue qui a été brûlé et qui
peut plus utilisés aujourd'hui ses mains
il obtient de faire de la rééducation
d'accord depuis cette affaire là la
police nationale les effectifs de la
police nationale ont créé une
association le mouvement d'épaulé c'est
en colère pour justement dire notre
ras-le-bol à l'administration dire notre
ras-le-bol osé lui dire notre ras-le-bol
à l'état pour dire aujourd'hui on est
effectivement il ya un manque de
considération mais on est le seul
rempart aujourd'hui dans l'est dans les
quartiers populaires vous avez plus
d'éducation nationale vous n'avez plus
de social on est les seuls aujourd'hui à
entrer à entrer il est représenté l'état
c'est ça et à faire du social et social
qui a pas d'autre fonction première
c'est pas notre fonction programme
effectivement mais on est là pour
assurer la sécurité de l'ensemble des
français n'est pas uniquement justement
le problème est qu'aujourd'hui il ya des
gens banlieue quand il voit un policier
même s'ils ont rien fait ils n'ont qu'à
y être parce qu'ils n'ont rien ou
cassez-vous pillards tant qu'il ya ceux
qui partent au courant parce qu'ils ont
peur parce qu'il n'y a plus de dialogue
verra pas parce que c'est dans le
dialogue moi j'aimerais bien content
qu'on travaille ensemble moi je vous
regarde dans les yeux je vous dis
travaillons ensemble pourra pour
améliorer et c'est leur avoir votre
tribune ont même appris la tribune m et
les honnêtement ma tribune je rends
hommage de manière vive a dit riesch qui
ont déjà bits dans l'essonne jeu comment
s'appellent les collègues de magnanville
très honnêtement je ne sais pas
d'ailleurs nous touche c'est la gravité
de la situation le fait de ne pas avoir
assez parlé entre guillemets d'amour ça
va paraître
assez avoir parlé d'amour par rapport
aux gens de banlieue de ne pas les
considérer par rapport même à la police
ne pas avoir d' avoir creusé creusé
l'écart entre on a on en arrive à des
jeunes qui n'ont rien à faire grands
brûlés des flics mode dans mon éducation
jamais mes parents m'ont dit c'est ici
que des jeunes que j'étais de l'autre
côté des flics capable de faire ce qui
s'est passé avec théo donc la situation
n'est pas là où on s'est tiré dessus at
elle on doit plus réfléchir comment
colmater la brèche et rendre
hommage aux héros du quotidien oui on a
dans les urines aujourd'hui on attend
aussi la légion d'honneur
est-ce que je vais
ouvrir juste juste de revenir sur oseo
hero 2 du code du quotidien héros du
quotidien qui s'appelle marin qui a
sauvé un couple d'amoureux et qui s'est
retrouvé dans le coma sa maman j'ai
écouté le discours de sa maman s'appelle
audrey qu'il utilisait ce gamma devrait
recevoir la légion d'honneur c'est des
héros du quotidien il ya un serveur à
l'assemblée nationale qu a voulu sauver
des d un couple de vieux qui se faisait
agresser il est toujours dans le coma
absolue ce sont les héros du quotidien
je suis avec s'éroder codjia la police
je n'ai pas attendu des bleus bleus
bataclan les attentats pour pouvoir pour
avoir envie d'embrasser un policier mais
un moment donné ce que j'ai fait sur
cette tribune c'est blaise la bbc a hâte
à l'égout et embrasse les couilles vas-y
la mise mais nous y allons trouver les
dites moi comment on peut faire
travailler ensemble vraiment comme je le
fais au quotidien
nous sommes demandé la mobilisation du
mouvement des pollutions colère
demandent qu'il y ait des états généraux
de la police en place tout de suite
après les élections présidentielles mais
pas uniquement police c'est de réunir
l'ensemble des institutions qui
travaillent pour la société justice
sociale éducateurs de rue élus locaux
police et voilà qu'on compte qu'on
déclenche 7,7 cette réunion et qu'il
mette les choses à plat on n'est pas
entre le débat où on est dans le symbole
les jeunes de 41 question est ce qu'on
va vers la guerre civile en france
stéphane
regarde droit dans les yeux je vous dis
que si nos politiques si notre
administration si la société n'évolue
pas la société reste important aussi
water il risque d'y avoir effectivement
du désordre dans ce pays virginie
écoutez moi je me suis enlevé investi en
politique il ya très peu de temps j'ai
pas la prétention de croire qu'on peut
tout changer en étant politique et
souvent vous critiquer les politiques
mais je crois qu'il faut se rendre
compte de ce travail de qui est là aussi
pour qu'à un moment donné on soit dans
un mieux vivre ensemble est ce mieux
vivre ensemble ils passent aussi
effectivement par une jeunesse dans les
banlieues c'est pour ça que l'emploi est
la cause numéro un mais à ce que je
sache que le chômage et notamment le
chômage des jeunes est un fléau qui
touche tout particulièrement les
banlieues et c'est pour ça que
l'économique est aussi un levier pour
aller mieux dans ce pays stevie est ce
qu'on va vers la guerre civile
ça sent pas bon j'en tombe là je veux
vous dire ma fille et moi j'ai vu avec
ça avec avec cette tribune et les coups
de massue que je prends sur la tête et
menaçant envers mon fils et ma famille
donc je sens il ya un climat qui n'est
pas bon mais en même temps moi je suis
je suis je suis comme tout le monde moi
j'ai espoir je me suis aussi engagé en
politique parce que j'ai espoir je me
suis engagé je suis venu ici parce que
je savais que je veux juste que j'avais
pouvoir discuter avec avait avec le avec
ce policier et j'ai surtout envie de
dire venez on se tend la main on fait un
truc à plat ensemble et si vous avez
besoin d'eux des deux d'artistes ou
votent pour
vous pour aller plus loin dans ce que
vous demandez il est impossible vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure comment ils
ont pas de moyens ils n'ont pas de
moyens pas de voiture des jeunes pour
des voilà dans les ordinateurs alors
maintenant je n'oublie pas les brebis
galeuses cette minorité qui pose
problème et qui jette l'opprobre sont
toutes à polly ok merci à tous c'est est
salutaire votre taux du samedi avec
michèle
biagi
toi
ce taux
à
merci à tous et pour moi les adore cette
émission
la semaine prochaine à 19 heures salle
d'ici là au revoir l'émission c'est lui
point fr seuls les tonnes
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu